[Musik]
hollywood wasser vorjahr
ernsthaft herzlich willkommen monats
fünf minuten und zwar haben die kids
gerade ferien und wir haben uns den
blick wir brauchen wir schnell es zu
essen und möchten das trotzdem frisch
zubereiten und die mama ist gerade nicht
mehr richtig wo ist die mama okay wir
haben uns gedacht machen wir was mit
würstchen weil die samira und die
energie mögen würstchen sorg habe ich
recht maxi würstchen und haben uns
gedacht wir machen unseren kunden
adventskranz aus würstchen und backen
einfach was zusammen etwas zu essen und
b verbringen zeit miteinander
richtig also dann fangen wir an
samira und ella ok haben wir den zutaten
an
ich habe hier ein kilogramm würstchen
und zwar diesen vom türken werde zum
töten hingeht und sagt ihr möchtet asis
ossis haben dann bekommen dann will ich
diese dieses ossis und die können dann
scharf oder im normal haben ihr habt ein
schaf geholt die schmecken richtig
lecker das ist ja so ist es dann haben
wir hier mal blätterteig ein planet
peppiger blätterteig und er fertigt im
blätterteig der ist sogar vegan
ja genau und ich habe im blätterteig und
fertigen
dann haben wir hier schwarzkümmel
türkischen schwarzkümmel ganz ganz
wichtig kein kreuz gremium wohl kreuz
gehört aber auch kohl aber schwarz
können wir hier dann brauchen wir noch
ein ei und das war es eigentlich schon
okay also das erste was wir machen ist
wie ausschneiden die würstchen in vier
teile okay das ganz einfach zumachen
schatz machen wir folgendes die
würstchen eigentlich mal so auslegen
genauso breit wie es besser jetzt machen
wir erstmal die hälfte ok electric
erst die hälfte und aus der hälfte
machen noch einmal die hälfte haben wir
schon ein viertel richtig hier
nachbarschaft war er das gesehen ist ein
scharfes messer ja mama ist leider nicht
da und du hast jetzt hausarrest ihr
müsst mir helfen jetzt pass auf jetzt
mal wieder die hälfte und noch mal die
hälfte
mal die hälfte
ok jetzt haben wir hier die würde die
würstchen geviertelt jetzt nehmen wir
den fertigen blätterteig einfach aus
rolle so und den fertigen blätterteig
da hat das nennt man bis sie glatt oder
künstler auch mit messer schneiden ist
ja auch kein problem
genau und das machen wir ein bisschen
kleiner als die viertel lang mal und
jetzt macht mansiz papa jetzt macht das
schneidet das jetzt hier okay
[Musik]
das machst du folgende cella jetzt nimmt
es das bürstchen und thusis einrollen
okay genau
langsam langsam schön langsam los ein
rollendes würstchen hast ganz toll
gemacht deswegen dass man auf die seite
und was und wie sie geht auch mal genau
dargestellt was größe genau festlege was
man hier drauf
magst du wirst du magst du auch den papa
magst du papa meisten und da magst du ab
[Musik]
hast du alle aufgezählt
jetzt haben die würstchen eingeholt der
leist abgehauen
jetzt haben wir diese pizza black das
habt ihr auch ein rundes blech ist nicht
immer ein vorteil über das hat jetzt
immer dieses pizza blech dann schneiden
wir einfach hier ein bisschen was papi
auf das backpapier mal falten
[Musik]
resultat perfekt ok den trick hab ich
meiner mama ja jetzt haben dass gewaltig
was auf sie jetzt zuerst papa mal wird
zusammenfalten
jetzt hat man das in die mitte genau
also dass sie hier schon mal richtig
brennen kommt sie dann wieder so dann
wieder so das riskio schere schneiden
ich warte ich machtlos
unverschämtheit ist immer wechseln
ok jetzt haben das so gemacht und jetzt
so schön wie so ein adventskranz an
ihrer tour einfach mal die würstchen
außenrum legen richtig
versaut dann machen wir nochmal ein
blech okay kannst du mal aufschlagen
schafft
[Musik]
genau das macht schön mit dem
einstreichen okay wir machen das in die
mitte und jetzt einfach schön
einschränken okay
[Musik]
so jetzt haben was eingestrichen jetzt
noch ein bisschen schwarzkümmel und
mache ein bisschen schwarzkümmel drauf
es gibt noch dieses dieses diesen coolen
geschmack jetzt schieben was bei 200
grad 30 minuten lang in den ofen
[Musik]
samira gemacht und sagen was ein
bisschen dekoriert und jetzt haben uns
gedacht ist doch mal alle probieren oder
wen rufen jetzt alles und mal so
jetzt kommen die alle her jungs und
mädels aus dem team wo wir jetzt mal
alle was wir zwei gemacht haben das hat
er gemacht wir haben würstchen im
blätterteig gemacht ganz ganz einfach
das könnte heim wirklich wirklich auch
innerhalb von fünf minuten im advent
kann ja außer habe zwei linke hände
wieder grün
da könnte ich nicht innerhalb von fünf
minuten machen dann würde ich mich
wahrscheinlich dass auch nicht
hinbekommen jetzt probiert mal jeder 1
kommt los haben sie angst vor ihren
jungs ich habe jetzt nur eins gase und
nicht wieder andere haben diese männer
haben mich dass ossis
und ja auch das jetzt das sieht deine
vier mhh noch so kleine nummer
alex rühle ein bisschen schneller
so auch das aussehen aber das heißt noch
nicht
also passt super gebrachten super dank
der in blätterteig man dank ist amira
daniela wie gesagt problem ist aus ganz
ganz einfach ganz schnell und sieht echt
hübsch ist ja eine schöne weihnachtszeit
auf jeden fall okay
tschüss macht's gut dass jetzt unsere
weihnachtsfeier nein ja stimmt genau
weihnachtsfeier war es würde ich es ja
vorher ja niemand uns neues jahr im
schlafrock und wir sehen uns dann nach
den heiligen drei könige wieder wenn wir
glück haben sind könig nie mehr wieder
kehrt der onkel könig den hat er doch
mit ja
[Musik]